sushi chef kazayuki tanioca used to
purchase this fish from Southern Japan
these days he's forced to buy it from
Southern China authorities here have
banned Seafood from 10 Japanese regions
and all Japanese food imports are
experiencing long delays at Customs the
move has hurt business
on one hand it's no longer possible to
import ingredients from Japan and on the
other hand some customers are worried
that the discharge of contaminated water
will affect food safety
Beijing is protesting against Japan's
plan to release more than a million tons
of treated radioactive water from its
damage Fukushima nuclear plant into the
Pacific Ocean the un's nuclear Watchdog
has approved the plan but Chinese
officials say the long-term risks are
unknown
China urges Japan to heat legitimate
concerns of International Community and
its own Citizen and to hold his plan for
discharging the nuclear-contaminated
water into sea
Chinese State media have highlighted
demonstrations against the plan in Japan
South Korea and the Pacific Islands
this area in downtown Beijing is known
as Little Tokyo and it's full of
restaurants that serve sushi and other
Japanese Cuisine we visited many of them
and they all told us that business has
been badly affected by China's
restrictions on Japanese seafood
it's raised tensions with Tokyo though
China Remains the largest importer of
Japanese seafood
the safety of Japanese seafood products
have been scientifically verified the
government requests that the Chinese
side remove its restrictions the
Fukushima water release plan has divided
the scientific Community some are
calling for more research several
countries including China and the United
States also released nuclear Wastewater
into the sea we can continue to treat
our ocean as badly as we are today by
using it as a Dumping Ground for
everything that we don't want in our
backyard and expect the ocean to be able
to protect lives for generations to come
kazuyuki tanioka says he's taking things
day by day his restaurant survived the
pandemic he's hopeful it will survive
the storm over the Fukushima water
release plan too katrinau Al Jazeera
thank you